video came out on Friday of Kamala
Harris the vice president again a woman
who was polling at zero in her own party
when the people behind Biden picked her
to be the vice president talked about
giving resources based on Equity I I saw
this video on Friday night I cannot tell
you how absolutely enraged I was when I
saw this take a look
it is our lowest income communities and
our communities of color that are most
impacted by these extreme conditions and
and impacted by by issues that are not
of their own making and so we
absolutely and so we have to address
this in a way that is about giving
resources based on Equity understanding
that we we fight for equality but we
also need to fight for Equity
understanding not everyone starts out at
the same place and if we want people to
be in an equal Place sometimes we have
to take into account those disparities
look Kamala Harris is is racist she
she's racist she is not bright
um she's pretending to be vice president
I mean I get I get it it says it on on
the placard on her desk but this woman
is an absolute clown and and what she
said right there is completely the
antithesis of the American ethos we have
equality not Equity it does not matter
that we do not all start at the same
place some people are really are born
really rich and with all the skills in
the world some people are born poor with
no skills some people have great
physical attributes some people are
somewhere in between bad things happen
to good people all of those things
America is the promise of opportunity
the idea that the vice president of the
United States during one of the biggest
hurricanes to ever hit an American state
would say that we will give resources
based on Equity to communities of color
you know it's this when I said to trade
before that there's this meme out there
that this whole area Southwest Florida
because the beaches are so and I said
it's all these rich people first off if
a rich person losing their house is as
unfortunate and sad and disastrous as a
poor person losing their house now we
can talk about how the government should
come in and maybe it needs to put some
more resources to people who need it but
not based on skin color it's absolutely
disgusting it's anti-American and and
truly if they were able to put that into
play if the federal government was able
to put resources to help communities of
color more than communities of non-color
it would be against the Constitution of
the United States and if they try to do
it I hope that they'll impeach the the
old buffoon that she works for and and
get rid of her too these people are just
absolutely awful so when you
when your friends are saying to you oh
the woke stuff isn't so bad and all this
race stuff isn't so bad of the gender
stuff isn't so bad you see how it's
connected to to the very Machinery that
then is supposed to help people in times
of Crisis uh you know when on Sanibel
right when you get onto the island you
take a right off the causeway onto
Periwinkle Drive the main road over
there and there's a big community of
mobile homes you think these are rich
people I don't know what color they are
I've never thought about it never
thought about it I've been there because
they they used to have a little uh a
little petting zoo and some birds and
some things so I used to take my nieces
and nephews over there never once
thought about the color of the people
but it this is this is the vile toxic
ideas of the left that have permeated
government to the highest possible
levels that this woman dare think that
it is okay to look at a disaster area
and say we'll give more money to black
people than we will white people it is
racism pure and simple it's not Reverse
Racism them it's racism and she is
racist and she's a clown and she knows
she's a clown because she's even
laughing as she says it because yes we
have equality in the United States
Equity go go to Venezuela